everywhere you turn there are armed
police on every street corner down hotel
corridors and at the gates of Pakistan's
national cricket stadiums eleven years
ago terrorism casts Pakistan into the
sporting wilderness when Taliban gunmen
attack the Sri Lankan cricket team
dozens were injured and eight Pakistan
EES were killed international sport and
cricket in particular was banned now
over a decade later it's back I think
you know we've paid the price for what
happened in 2009 we've paid for the
price dearly for that financially
financially of emerging perspective
you've just been alienated from the
cricketing world we've lost a generation
I think probably from not having cricket
here and having stadiums that have been
left empty we've had to cover the cost
is the PCB of those stadiums to keep the
upkeep of those very much based on the
dream that international cricket would
come back one day and we needed to be
ready for that but the impact was much
deeper than pounds and rupees cricket on
the subcontinent is part of its identity
so sociologically and culturally
Pakistan has been hurting
[Applause]
this year for the first time the
Pakistan Super League a t20 franchise
tournament is being played fully on home
soil for years cricket stadiums right
across Pakistan have remained empty and
the Tollan fans has been immeasurable
but now with some of the world's biggest
stars playing in this cricket Madden
nation the matchday atmosphere is back
to what it once was
we've been deprived of it it's a very
good message to all around the world at
a part on the sequester one of the most
safe country in the world I can say and
we are hoping that big teams like
Australia England and maybe India can
come and play with us in on our turf
obviously we had a tough times but we
are trying our best Pakistan is trying
and this is what the message that is
going across all over the world that yes
we are on our feet back again there are
international players in this tournament
how long will it be until the world's
biggest international teams like England
and Australia follow suit it's been 15
years since the England cricket team
last toured here
Jason Roy and Marine Ally are two of
England's biggest stars they made their
own choice to spend over a month out in
Pakistan the main kind of issue
regarding coming over it was security
obviously there was been a lot of talk
about it in the media and and people say
a lot of things about it so of course
that's going to be at the forefront of
your mind you're a bit worried about
that but as far as that's all concerned
they've ticked every single box there's
not been any security concerns it's been
a bit crazy having the armored trucks in
the armoured buses and the security
guards always around you and stuff
that's been an experience but I haven't
felt unsafe at any stage which is which
is a guess of Plus I'm sure we'd
probably be asked when we get back about
what was like and experience and
security all these kind of questions so
to be part of that is obviously great I
think being current Blazers are still
Lecky I'm Jason Roy guys that that
who've really enjoyed it I think will
maybe hopefully play a big part in us
coming with England side or an
Australian side or whatever which would
be a message to our going forward do you
see that happening quite soon do you
think I think so I mean it's it's still
gonna take a bit of time I think but
hopefully there'll be less we've done
something to almost push it forward and
their thoughts are record by England
batsman Alex Hales and bowler Chris
Jordan as overseas players we're all
trying to play our part and that we all
understand how big cricket is in this
country no maybe now we've experienced
it firsthand it's just it's absolutely
May and the people go ballistic for it
here so to play a part in bringing such
an important part of this country's
culture back to the country is you know
we feel privileged to do that
do you see Jay feel that the England
cricket team could be out here within
say the next 18 24 months perhaps part
of that setup as everything's in place
as it has been here I can't see I can't
see why why that's not a possibility
more than 25,000 police ranges and
special forces have been used across the
country to make sure this event is
completed safely Pakistan knows it only
has one chance to get this right it
probably gives me some more sleepless
nights than anything else not because
there are any threats but you just know
that the behavior of one individual
somewhere along the line
our focus is very much on the future
controlling what we can't control you
would just hope that everything
continues to go well for us but you know
there's always an eagle at the end of
your mind of course there is you know
you can set us back 10 years if anything
was to be was to happen
this country still has questions to
answer over its reintroduction to the
international fold the long-standing
tensions in its relationship with India
remain although the terrorist threat
isn't what it was what's been achieved
by the Pakistan super league shouldn't
be underestimated
once again Sports has rehabilitated a
pariah the onus now is on the cricketing
world more widely to respond in kind
intima Machine Sky News in Pakistan
[Applause]